[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi
1er mars tout de suite les titres de
cette édition c'est la neuvième année
consécutive que la compétition cycliste
s'élance des yvelines le 76e paris nice
débutent dimanche départ de chatou le
lendemain la course au soleil partira de
la plus petite ville étape
or son ville comment la commune de moins
de 400 habitants se prépare-t-elle à
recevoir les coureurs et spectateurs son
maire anne cabri est notre invité le
salon de l'agriculture poursuit sa route
jusqu'à dimanche porte de versailles à
paris le rendez vous met en lumière
notamment les exploitants yvelinois le
département compte environ 40% de
surface cultivée que faut-il savoir de
ce secteur sur le territoire chronique à
suivre et puis c'est une grande fête
autour des robots la rencontre régionale
des trophées de la robotique est au
programme ce samedi à la ferme du manet
de montigny le bretonneux
nous recevons arthur di fabio co
coordinateur de l'événement
[Musique]
le département des yvelines qui s'est
levé ce matin avec un voile blanc sur le
sol de la neige est tombée cette nuit
entre 1 et 3 cm elle n'a pas tenu la
vigilance orange est repassée au jaune
depuis 14 heures ce jeudi après-midi et
pas de grosse pagaille comme on l'a
connu il ya quelques semaines l'épisode
a été anticipé et les routes déneigée et
salée même si quelques bus ne circulait
pas ce matin elle les poids lourds
peuvent eux de nouveau circuler sur la
n118 est les températures vont remonter
progressivement le retour devrait se
poursuivre la semaine prochaine
ce dimanche s'élancera donc la 76e
édition du paris-nice depuis 2010 la
course au soleil par des yvelines plus
de 150 coureurs s'élanceront de chatou
pour la première étape elle passera
notamment par des communes de saint
quentin en yvelines les détails avec
mélanie poker après bois d'arcy l'an
dernier c'est au tour de chatou
d'accueillir la course au soleil
135 km à travers les yvelines avant de
rejoindre les hauts-de-seine un départ
fictif jusqu'à saint germain en laye et
à la sortie de saint germain en laye un
départ réel pour aller sur sur
villepreux sur ben
sur les mais nul et on va les chercher
toutes les toutes les côtes qui sont qui
sont qui sont dans les yvelines dont
certains
connaissent notamment la côte de 17
tours ans on va les chercher à coups de
boules et les trous aller chercher la
coupe de châteaufort mais côté stèle
jacques anquetil donc ça parle aussi des
mots sont les endroits qui parle et un
retour sur saint quentin en yvelines
des difficultés de circulation seront à
prévoir la course entraînera des
fermetures
quatre communes saint quentinois sont
concernés villepreux magny les hameaux
voisins le bretonneux et montigny le
bretonneux 154 coureurs seront au départ
de cette première étape une étape qui
devrait sourire aux sprinteurs l'an
dernier c'était arnaud démare qui
s'était imposé arnaud démare qui était
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui sur la piste du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le coureur de
la fdj a s'est entraîné pendant deux
heures ce midi pour parfaire sa
condition physique est loin du froid et
de la neige à 26 ans il souhaite
rééditer la performance de l'année
dernière dans le département on lit côte
on les écoute au micro de mélanie poker
et de me caler l'hydro de c1 il fait
vraiment mauvais en son nom un pain
mauvais mais vraiment très froid un peu
partout de moi chez moi ce matin et -4°
donc je me suis dit je veux venir
je me rends au vélodrome il fera
beaucoup beaucoup mieux pour rouler et
puis
et puis voilà ça que c'est quand même
intéressant d'avoir un incident comme ça
j'ai roulé j'ai roulé que les abonnés
sur le créneau de 12h 14h et puis là
j'aimerais faire quelques exercices
première étape de ce paris nice donc au
départ de chatou dimanche le lendemain
lundi 5 mars la deuxième étape
s'élancera de la plus petite ville étape
du tracé or sont ville dans le sud
yvelines communes de moins de 400 âmes
qui s'apprête donc à recevoir la course
cycliste bonsoir anne cabri saf
vous êtes la mère d'orson ville alors on
est à quatre jours de cette étape au
départ d'or sont violés ce que l'on
l'engouement monte petit à petit oui la
l'engouement montrent les jours
approchant à quatre jours du départ
l'argument maintes les personnes se
mobilisent tous les mêmes bénévoles sont
sur leurs starting blocks
on a 40 environ 40 personnes qui seront
présentes avec nous lundi matin à partir
de 5 heures pour préparer d'accord voilà
donc à une vraie effervescence à
quelques jours du départ est-ce que tout
est fin prêt on aura peut-être
l'occasion après de reparler de cette
préparation est ce qu'il reste des
choses encore à régler à la marge mais
l'essentiel est prêt alors avant de
continuer cet entretien je vous propose
d'écouter les raisons du choix d'orson
ville écouter l ambassadeur de la course
thomas voeckler et le directeur du paris
nice moi je trouve ça bien parce que le
vélo c'est pas que le tour de france des
épreuves comme paris nice ça permet
aussi à des communes qui n'ont peut-être
pas toujours les moyens d'accueillir le
tour de france afin d'avoir une épreuve
cycliste de renom avec des coureurs de
renom et et puis ben faire plaisir à
tout le monde aux habitants aux gamins
des écoles pas loin en quoi c
bien paris nice doit aller comme dans
toutes les courses et qui d'ailleurs
doit aller partout doit partir de
n'importe quel village on sait que les
grands stades sont dans les grandes
villes
le stade 2 le stade de paris nice il
peut se dépasser dans les toutes petites
villes 400 habitants c'est cesser une
petite commune mais c'est nécessaire à
notre fonctionnement d'aller d'aller un
petit peu partout et donc ça va faire
drôle d'avoir la caravane de paris nice
qui sera qui sera au départ d'une si
petite ville aura doublé la population
peut-être pas là triplé mais au moins la
doubler
donc c'est bien ça on parle du sud du
département tout de suite on va en
valais dans la bosse donc encore une
fois en espèrant quai du vent inquiet du
vent qui souffle d'ouest pour pour avoir
du spectable s'est désolé c'est désolant
si je dis ça avec des coureurs pour les
power mai mais quelque part nous
organisateurs c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on recherche aussi mais des
interviews réalisées en janvier dernier
par michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude au conseil
départemental des des yvelines anne
fabricant vous avez su que or sont ville
allait recevoir cette deuxième étape
quelle a été votre réaction c'était une
grande fierté pour notre village parce
que comme l'a dit le directeur monsieur
le marchand on ne s'attendait pas qu'une
si petite commune moins de 400 elle
puisse recevoir un événement si
important donc c'était une grande fierté
pour le village et pour le monde rural
nous luttons pour une commune comme ans
on vit moins de 400 habitants ou lundi
on attend plus de 1000 personnes
une médiatisation aussi plus plus de 100
journalistes accrédités une compétition
qui sera diffusée dans 190 pays qu'est
ce que ça représente d'accueillir le
paris nice alors le paris-nice et la
course du soleil par excellence donc le
soleil sera le 5 mars sur horse en ville
tous les flashs seront sur ce petit
village
ça représente s'est montrée au delà du
village d'orson ville s'est montré la
valeur de nos villages ruraux que dans
la ruralité on a la chance de pouvoir
recevoir des courses sportives de haut
niveau et que ce soit accessible à tout
le monde et montrer qu'il ya des
richesses également dans nos villages
donc je voulais vraiment remercier
amaury sport organisation et le conseil
départemental qui nous ont permis de
pouvoir porter ce projet c'est très bien
pour tous les habitants et on partage ça
avec tous mes collègues maires une
commune dont la population sera doublée
voire même plus un lundi comment la
commune dans son village se
prépare-t-elle justement à recevoir tout
ce monde on pense forcément vous en avez
dit deux mots tout à l'heure à
l'importance des bénévoles
alors cette organisation se prépare
depuis l'annnonce du 9 janvier du
parcours se prépare avec les élus parce
que dont nous qui vit là
retroussons nos manches pour travailler
en lien avec la sécurité de la
préfecture et des bénévoles là on est à
peu près à 40 bénévoles dont l' us
cycliste de poids ni rambouillet qui
nous aide parce qu'ils ont leurs
connaissances sur ces courses cyclistes
soient amateurs soit professionnel mais
cette journée de lundi à quoi
ressemblera tellement c'est le prêt tôt
pour vous on a commencé très tôt par
pour les bénévoles afin de préparer
l'organisation mais après le démarrage
via une animation du village à partir de
10 heures
des animations pour les enfants parce
qu'on va accueillir 80 enfants de nos
écoles rurales de boujan de presse et
ensuite la course passe lancé à 11
heures où les tous les coureurs vont se
présenter sur un podium et le départ
fictif est à midi le départ est à 12h05
on imagine des accès bloqués lundi sur
sur la commune abel la commune est
tellement grande que le centre bourg
sera bloqué à partir de 6 heures du
matin les gens passeront par un autre
village par paris doivent ils pour venir
se ressemblent pour soumis seront bien
évidemment facilement guider parce qu'il
y aura plein de gendarmes de sécurité
qui dès lors les dirigeront vers les
déviations indiqué que vous en disiez de
mots pour préparer cet événement la
commune dans son village à impliquer les
enfants 80 jeunes des écoles qui seront
présents ce lundi sur l'étape et vous
avez organisé un concours de dessin
autour de la thématique du vélo tout à
fait avec le corps enseignant qui s'est
mobilisé à 400%
on est parti sur le thème du vélo et de
la course cycliste donc ils ont fait 80
dessins partant de la maternelle à
l'élémentaire demain on se réunit avec
plusieurs élus pour décerner trois prix
et ses trois gagnants viendront faire
dédicacer leurs desseins lundi matin par
les quatre maillots maillot jaune le
maillot vert meilleur pour le maillot
blanc et ils viendront avec moi pour le
départ
couper le ruban du paris nice se dire
qu'il eut un projet pédagogique mené
autour du vélo les enseignants ont joué
le jeu
ah les enseignants ce vraiment se sont
mobilisés on sait très bien que sont les
enseignants les enfants pouvaient pas la
suivre derrière et là on a vraiment un
engouement des parents d'élèves s'il
faut pas les oublier des enfants et des
enseignants
la deuxième étape du paris nice au
départ d'or sont ville donc ce lundi 5
mars quatre kilomètres de course dans
les yvelines avant de rejoindre vierzon
après 187 km rester avec nous à anne-k
brink chronique qui pourrait vous
intéresser va suivre elles concernent
l'agriculture bonsoir à nicolas landry
ce soir grégory de la rédaction de tv 78
le salon international de la grille
culture se conclut ce dimanche 4 mars à
paris c'est un événement qui regroupe
notamment des agriculteurs et
producteurs yvelinois c'est l'occasion
pour nous de faire le point sur le
secteur agricole dans le département
qu'en est il nicolas dans ce département
des yvelines
or vous le savez le département des
yvelines c'est un département des
vilains département deschamps un mélange
entre zones rurales comme chez vous
madame cabris et des zones urbaines
comme à saint quentin en yvelines avec
environ 40% de surface cultivée près de
1000 exploitations et plus de 2000
emplois dans ce secteur les yvelines se
classe second territoire agricole d'île
de france
on précise que la seine-et-marne et
devant les yvelines alors quels types
d'exploitations ne retrouve-t-on dans ce
département en principales cultures les
céréales et exploitation de colza par
exemple avec plus de 80 % de surfaces
cultivées viennent ensuite des activités
de polyculture ou de maraîchage avec des
fruits et légumes
à noter aussi la présence sur le
territoire de 345 éleveurs on comprend
que l'agriculture occupe une place
importante dans les yvelines est ce que
le secteur se porte bien pour autant et
bien grégory il faut quand même
relativiser les chiffres que je viens de
citer si on prend l'évolution sur ces 30
dernières années l'activité agricole
dans les yvelines connaît un net recul
en 1988 on côté plus de deux mille
exploitations soit une baisse de 50%
même constat pour le nombre d'employés
dans le secteur avec plus de 5000 actifs
au début des années 90 soit une perte de
3000 emplois des trente dernières années
sur les 30 dernières dernière un des
facteurs explicatifs à ce phénomène
c'est l'urbanisation du territoire et
blinois ce qui entraîne une perte de
foncier c'est à dire la terre agricole
utilisée par les agriculteurs
merci à nicolas pour ces détails alors
un cabri vous êtes également conseillère
régionale déléguée spécial auprès de la
présidente valérie pécresse à
l'agriculture et la ruralité nicolas
landry qui vient d'évoquer la
problématique du manque de terres pour
les agriculteurs est ce que c'est un
dossier sur lequel vous vous êtes engagé
à la région ile de france
tout à fait c'est une annonce qui a été
faite lundi soir pour l'inauguration de
ce temps du stand de la région au salon
de l'agriculture
on va le voter le 31 mai au sein du
conseil régional on va voter notre pacte
régional agricole et au sein de ce pacte
agricole
il va y avoir tout un volet sur la
protection du foncier
il sera porté par l' agence des espèces
vert dont je préside et ce pacte
agricole sur le foncier avec une nouveau
dispositif qui est là en fait pour aider
nos jeunes agriculteurs à s'installer on
sait qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé
c'est le foncier qui est très rare et
très cher en ile de france et bien
évidemment dans les yvelines
donc ce nouveau dispositif qu'on va
appeler ile-de-france se terrent
d'installation va permettre de faire du
stockage au foncier pour nos jeunes
agriculteurs et bien sûr l'idéal après
et de leur transmettre
merci al karim d'avoir été avec nous
mais je rappelle vous êtes la mère
d'orson ville et délégué spécial à la
région ile-de-france donc délégué une
délégation spéciale à l'agriculture et
la ruralité merci beaucoup
c'était un engagement électoral
d'emmanuel macron faire émerger des
projets citoyens pour régler des
problèmes du quotidien
la formule prend forme dans les yvelines
avec une rencontre organisée hier
mercredi à versailles entre marcheurs du
département est les porteurs de projets
ont pu présenter leurs initiatives
nicolas kirillovitch étaient sur place
assis le regard fixe et attentif ces
marcheurs et coups de pierres un
versailles et qui a l'idée de remplacer
le noir par du blanc dans les villes ra
mètres carrés un mètre carré de surface
noire
c'est comme si vous mettez deux
radiateurs de
si on arrive à avoir une vie qui est
plutôt blanche on aura moins de
réchauffement de la ville
et si on allait vite plutôt noir on va
voir une surchauffe de la ville alors on
peut le faire chez soi sur sa terrasse
du jardin
on peut le faire quand on est membre d
un conseil syndical du blanc à la place
du noir l'avantagé surtout pour
l'environnement il intéresse aussi les
habitants invités à donner leur avis et
conseils
j'apporte par contre mon père mon
oreille le citoyen est donc de réagir à
une idée qui m'est proposé est de prêter
le challenger on a fait à l'aise j'ai
pas comme sur le coup sûr comment
déployer ce genre d'idée savoir s'il y
avait des effets micro c'était que des
effets macro une dizaine de porteurs de
projets étaient présents pour ces
ateliers citoyens la république en
marche se fixe dans les yvelines la mise
en place de 130 projets locaux d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
éducation sociale ou encore santé
l'objectif est d'inciter les citoyens à
régler par eux mêmes les problèmes de
tous les jours
nous sommes tous en mesure de régler des
problèmes à notre échelle
par exemple nous avons lancé un projet
de seniors fake pour lutter contre la
fracture numérique des aînés qui sont
souvent qu'ils savent pas trop comment
gérer l'ordinateur alors que de plus en
plus de choses se font sur ordinateur et
à champniers est un projet qui est lancé
lancé également en direction des
prochaines élections ces ateliers ont
pour but politique de faire émerger des
marcheurs en vue des élections
municipales de 2020 à voisins le
bretonneux la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse recherche des familles
relais elles auront pour mission
d'accueillir à des mineurs ou jeunes
majeurs au titre de l'enfance
délinquante un accueil à temps plein ou
sur des week ends vacances il faut avoir
une personnalité affirmée et avoir des
qualités d'écouté de dialogue de
pédagogie mais aussi de la fermeté est
les familles sont indemnisés à hauteur
de 36 euros par jour plus d'informations
auprès de la directrice de
l'établissement dont le numéro s'affiche
permettre l'insertion des personnes en
situation de handicap grâce au travail
objectif de l'association delos api 78
est la structure dispose de deux esat
dans les yvelines ce sont là des
établissements et services d'aidé par le
travail des entreprises adaptées pour
les travailleurs comme a pu le constater
hier nicolas kirillovitch abus que le
travail se fait en équipe
nettoyez préparer et séchez les boîtes
en plastique qui seront ensuite utilisés
pour le vrac alimentaire et l'impression
d'être dans une entreprise classique
pourtant les travailleurs sont en
situation de handicap
ils sont plus de 150 dans cet
établissement spécialisé pour la plupart
ils sont polyvalents voir
multicompétence c'est à dire que ben ils
peuvent travailler dans cet atelier a
sur un process spécifiques de lavage de
boîte mais ils peuvent aller dans un
autre atelier après pour faire autre
chose dans cette structure près d'une
trentaine de métiers sont proposés de la
blanchisserie avec une machine qui
repasse elle même les chemins
ou de la sous traitance industrielle
pour des missions de conditionnement ou
de la préparation de commandes
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que quand ils sortent de les at il y ait
peu de différence entre ce qu'ils ont
vécu à lézat tu es ce qui pourrait vivre
dans une entreprise dite normale pour
faciliter l'insertion professionnelle
des travailleurs l'établissement est
aussi doté d'un espace médico-social
sept personnes présentes pour
accompagner et répondre à des besoins
parfois spécifiques qu'on est quand même
d'un accompagnement adapté de la
personne donc oui c'est qu'on va prendre
à temps avec la personne quand ça va pas
bien pour comprendre pourquoi
soit à peine sur le plan personnel mais
aussi le plein travail différent que
collègues 35 heures de travail par
semaine et une rémunération égale à un
smic une fois l'ensemble des allocations
additionner 24 établissements de ce
genre sont présents sur le département
des yvelines pour un taux d'insertion
professionnelle inférieur à 5%
une grande journée autour des robots la
rencontre ile-de-france des trophées de
robotique se tient ce samedi à la ferme
du manet de montigny le bretonneux au
programme de cette journée les trophée
régional de robotique bien sûr mais
aussi à plein et d'animation bonsoir
arthur di fabio bonsoir vous êtes co
coordinateur de l'événement dont qui est
organisée par l'association planète
sciences ile de france on n'en dira de
mode en un instant troisième année
consécutive que cette rencontre se tient
à montigny-le-bretonneux c'est la
capitale de la robotique la capitale
régionale de la robotique ontinyent le
bretonneux
ah bah alors depuis trois ans un petit
peu puisque c'est une aussi une volonté
de la ville de noeux de nous proposer la
fait la ferme du manet comme lieu en mai
après c'est évidemment ces équipes de
toute l'île de france qui se rassemble à
montigny ce samedi alors c'est un
événement je vais dit qui est organisée
par l'association planète sciences ile
de france pour présenter l'association
quels sont ses objectifs
alors la planète sciences ile de france
est une association qui agit sur la
culture si les scientifiques et
techniques par la démarche de projet
donc par les animations scientifiques au
long terme
sur la robotique ça peut être
l'archéologie l'astronomie ce genre de
thématique pour toutes à tout type d'âge
tout public troisième édition à monter
bretons eux ça fait plusieurs années que
se tient ces journées de la robotique
régional de robotique ah oui ça fait des
années que que ces rencontres se passe
un petit peu partout en ile-de-france
selon les lieux qui accueillent mais ça
se passe aussi
d'autre part en france pour d'autres
délégations nationales alors au
programme de la journée la finale
régionale des trophées de robotique elle
convie des équipes de jeunes de 7 à 18
ans la robotique pourquoi est elle
intéressante pour ces jeunes finalement
quelles connaissances à elle va leur
apporter la robotique ben alors déjà en
fait c'est savoir se servir de ses mains
puisque il fabrique un robot une partie
y partent de rien pour fabriquer un
robot et et puis après c'est des notions
d'electric délégué d'électronique voilà
et puis de travail en équipe puisque ce
sont des équipes constituées qui selon
un programme vont réaliser leurs robots
ils ont commencé en septembre
il arrive maintenant avec leurs robots
constitué qu'ils ont constitué ensemble
mais finalement plusieurs thématiques
qui sont nécessaires pour faire bien
bien marché le robot il ya plusieurs
aspects qui rentrent en jeu il ya
plusieurs aspects qui rentrent en jeu
puisque il ya un cahier des charges à
respecter pour le robot la taille
voilà et du coup ils l'ont construit ils
ont découvert comment le construire
puisque pour certains ils n'ont jamais
jamais fait de robots des fois ils
reviennent d'année en année et voilà est
en fait ils s'échangent leurs
connaissances entre eux tout autant
qu'avec leurs animateurs vous avez le
droit une aide justement pour apprendre
à construire un robot s'il ne
connaissait pas du tout le mode de
construction
oui oui évidemment ils ont des
animateurs à qui on propose des
formations ou alors c'est directement le
l'association planète sciences
ile-de-france qui anime certaines
équipes voilà c'est aussi les échanges
de connaissances
le partage de connaissances et puis le
fait d'apprendre
entre entre jeunes qui marche énormément
ces jeunes on travaille en équipe pour
construire des robots qu'on appelle
filoguidé quelques kits est ce que ça
veut dire que en fait de la télécommande
jusqu au robot il y a un fils on n'est
pas dans du sans fil
d'ailleurs d'être simplement il ya le
fils qui va de la télécommande au robot
tenu par une perche mais qui permet
quand même aux robots de se déplacer de
se déplacer chaque année il ya des défis
auxquelles doit répondre le robot là
cette année quelles qu'elles étaient les
défis fixés
alors le thème cette année c'est les
villes du futur donc on s'intéresse aux
défis des villes du futur à savoir
construire des bâtiments empiler des
cubes
ça peut être aussi remplir un château
d'eau puisque il est question des
besoins en eau il est aussi question de
toutes les thématiques un petit peu
environnementale donc ils auront une
abeille mécanique qui devra pseudo
butiner pour aller chercher un ballon
rond il se sera des petites épreuves
comme ça sur des tables où ils pourront
s'affronter sur ces épreuves
alors il y aura trente huit équipes qui
seront en lice donc ce samedi quatre
équipes yvelinoise on les cite l'équipe
jouvet de la maison de quartier louis
jouvet de montigny le bretonneux m6 tech
du mille club de maurepas trappe botte
du centre socioculturel luc-sur-aude de
trappes et être meilleur du skylab de
saint quentin en yvelines
on en a dit deux mots tout à l'heure
combien de temps ils ont disposé à l est
ont disposé de combien de temps ses
équipes pour monter leurs robots alors
en fait depuis depuis septembre ils se
rassemblent pour pour faire le robot est
en fait depuis environ novembre le
règlement est fixé et il savent à quoi
s'attendre et du coup ils s'entraînent
justement sur les épreuves qu'ils auront
à faire sur la table de jeu
elles seront départagées commencé ses
équipes par des épreuves qu est-ce qu à
la clé finalement samedi alors déjà ils
auront des phases de qualification où
pendant 90 secondes
ils s'affronteront avec un autre robot
table par table sur un système de points
quelles épreuves ils arrivent à faire et
ensuite apprécié phase de qualification
il y aura les phases finales qui sont
qualificatives pour la finale nationale
alors vous l'avez d'iliad et donc des
vainqueurs dans ce tournant mais aussi
des prix spéciaux qui seront décernés il
ya des prix spéciaux parce que sur 38
équipes on a des surprises on a des
robots particulier on a des équipes
particulière et en fait on a un jury
qui se rassemblent pendant la journée et
qui définit des prix spéciaux à
certaines équipes ça peut être prix du
fair-play prix du robot le plus original
et ce sont des prix qui peuvent être
qualificatif aussi pour la finale
nationale
comme quoi c'est pas uniquement une
question de performance au tour de cette
compétition et aussi des animations qui
sont proposées toute la journée on a nos
partenaires on and on a des partenaires
qui comme par exemple le skylab qui
proposeront des animations
principalement sur l'électronique sur
l'impression en 3d ce genre de choses et
on a aussi des sur la sur l'après midi
des animations sur l'environnement la
biologie par l'atelier des sciences qui
viendront proposer ça à tout public et
cette année on a même un pour les
équipes une équipe qui a fabriqué un
petit jeu de piste dans la ferme et du
banney merci à découvrir dit fabio
d'avoir été avec no mercy rappelle qu
coordinateur de la rencontre
ile-de-france des trophées de robotique
c'est ce samedi à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux et pour plus
d'informations je vous invite à vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
allez on referme ce journal sur une
touche de saveurs des sapins citronnée
pêche à la framboise ou poivre
pamplemousse voilà avec quelques
exemples de sirop originaux que vous
pouvez trouver chez l'alchimiste son
atelier boutique et à chevreuse il fait
découvrir son à savoir faire au public
camille lambert est allé suivre
l'élaboration d'une de ses créations
regarder
c'est plus long oui comme ça mais vous
avez vous rapprocher plus du véritable
groupe de la plante marque chenu est un
amoureux du goût depuis 20 ans il
travaille le produit brut pour en
extraire la véritable saveur et créent
des sirops aujourd'hui siro verveine
gingembre les bouteilles
réapprovisionneront la ferme de gally
chaque détail compte surtout la
température donc avoir effectué le sucre
déjà tu vas monter et va s'épaissir
moi si je faisais ça avec le gingembre
vu que celui la jambre frais je vais
changer le goût du vin sont déjà un peu
caramélisé doucement le gouverment
changer ça plus être pareil
moi je veux garder le côté frais du
gingembre la préparation n'ira donc pas
au delà de 70 degrés un véritable
travail d'alchimiste qui lui a valu le
nom de sa boutique ce sirop c'est le
début de son activité le premier d'une
longue série
installé à chevreuse depuis trois ans
marque propose aujourd'hui plus de 70
créations différentes aussi bien des
sureaux avec du poisson fumé du fromage
avec des fromages avec des légumes avec
des viandes donc savoir que le seront
peut être utilisé comme un condiment
comme une sauce c'est ça l'idée
il ya deux ans on a créé avec
champion de france de barista un sirop
qu'on a appelée velours de tahiti et qui
est à siros réalisé que la fleur de
tiaré fraîche et puis récemment il ya eu
un sirop de sapporo ma fruités épicés ou
prestigieux une gamme qui se décline
selon les envies marque organise des
ateliers pour faire découvrir son savoir
faire aux curieux et satisfaire les
palais des gourmands voilà c'est la fin
de ce set 8 journal merci de l'avoir
suivi demain vendredi
vous avez rendez vous avec le 7-8
l'hebdo présenter apparaît nicolas
kirillovitch pour revenir sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
et fait le plein d'idées de sorties pour
le week-end avec le 7-8 loisirs 2 et
camille lambert et cette édition comme
d'habitude un ces reportages sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]